all right president biden finally
uniting the country in agreement around
one notion the economy totally stinks a
majority of americans disapprove of
biden on nearly every key economic
concern
only 37 percent approve of his handling
of the economic recovery and joe gets
worse numbers on issues like gas prices
and inflation
nearly 80 percent of americans say the
economy is an extremely or very
important factor in how they will vote
the media trying to warn democrats of
what's to come
president biden is a serious drag on
democratic candidates nationwide and
it's driven by his approval rating on a
range of issues he is badly underwater
on all of the top issues including the
big ones inflation
gas prices he has less than 30 percent
approval rating on the issues that we're
told by voters are dominating their
state of mind
meanwhile gas prices hit a staggering
record high at 486 a gallon doubling
since biden's presidency began
but the administration is having no
problem passing the blame on their
economic woes
the price of gasoline is is not set by a
dial in the oval office and when an oil
company is deciding hour by hour how
much to charge you for a gallon of gas
they're not calling the administration
to ask what they should do they're doing
it based on their goal of maximizing
their profits gas prices
are up a dollar forty a gallon since
putin moved troops troops into
ukraine if you look at
what happened when putin started
amassing troops on the border with
russia the price of gas has increased by
a dollar and 51 cents
well there you go welcome back dana you
were missed by i wondered if people
would notice that i got suspended no
well i mean it was right before i mean
it was pretty awful what you said yeah
next time hold my hand before you yeah
and to retweet that uh was disgusting i
mean even david wouldn't do
i have a question for you though you
know you you this they've been doing
this before i think it was last week was
that president biden says we don't have
a switch to turn on baby formula in this
case it's mayor pete saying we don't
have a dial it's like we know that we
understand that there's no magic formula
but you are in charge so what the hell
are you doing we don't tell us you know
i wish i had a i wish i had a switch
so i had this pattern where they they
miss the problem or they misdiagnose it
then when it happens they try to say
well it's not going to be that bad
remember inflation's transitory um then
they realize oh crap we got a problem so
then they try to find someone to blame
and then that person's like wait you
can't blame me it's on you and then they
try to change the subject again and then
they constantly have him out there
saying oh um joe biden what he really
wants more than anything is to get out
in the country and travel more and be
out there more and let me just tell you
something no political or policy problem
has ever been solved in the history of
the world with a communication strategy
right and certainly not by somebody who
has not been able to answer the mail so
far on the baby formula one by the way
susan rice is the domestic policy
chairperson they went for months and
they didn't tell him that this was a
problem and he he went out and said well
if we were mind readers well you know
you don't have to be mind readers you
just have to like have competent staff
exactly it's like uh we're not mind
readers we don't have a switch you know
we don't have a dial it's always like
we're not asking you to be the any of
those things just do the right thing do
your damn job or get out of there judge
what is this this uh you hear this
scuttle butt which is a slang for a
gossip
uh that biden is seething he's seething
because his numbers are now lower than
trump
he was supposed to he was supposed to be
the antidote to trump yes and now he's
less popular yes and and here's the
amazing part of it but before i get to
that i love that you're back dana i
missed you for 10 days
nice to be back with who did you not
like
who did you know no i just love dana and
i'll leave it at that because she's
smart and she's quick and okay
you know what's amazing about joe biden
he thinks okay now that his numbers are
worse than donald trump he thinks he's
going to be able to go out into the
public and convince people that he is
shrewd he is smart he is capable of
turning it around
you know what joe get out there go out
there and talk to people if you can
put yourself out there and try to
explain to the american people why the
numbers are so bad why there is such a
cultural division between the right and
the left why 83 percent of the country
are not only worried about the economy
they're worried about the future of this
country they're worried about their
safety their security and they have
doubts for the first time i don't
remember reading about this you know
i just don't remember reading about it
they have doubts in the nation's
political system the democrats have so
trashed the system whether it's a
criminal justice system or the supreme
court system or the whole thing that
people are like maybe america isn't what
they said it was and we're going to have
to fix it
jessica in the green room you were you
said to me that wow if only biden had
concentrated on real issues instead of
this virtue signaling wokism we wouldn't
have the worst president in the history
of the united states i thought that was
so frank and honest of you care to
elaborate more on that it really was i'm
i'm glad that uh you know what's between
friends just stays what's between
friends in the green room
to the judge's point about everyone's
saying that they're scared of the future
of democracy
the last president tried to overturn
an election result and didn't mind if
his vice president got hanged for it so
if you wonder what institutional
she's not the president of the united
states of america are you sure that's
really her
oh my god okay
so i actually think because
now democrats are facing the potential
of losing seats that are at least lean
blue right like
bright bright blue is still going to be
fine so i think the president can serve
a purpose in terms of going talk and
talking to people who are likely to vote
for democrats or could still be
persuaded and then individual
congressmen and senators are going to
have to just figure out if they want
biden with them or not if if that makes
sense in terms of their district but the
frustration that's going on when you
look at the numbers and i can see
sitting there saying i've created over 8
million jobs in 15 months unemployment's
at 3.6 percent why is this going so
poorly
that i get the frustration and maybe his
staff should just say we have a few
months to fix this let him go right he
won the 2020 election going out there
gaff prone and all by getting out there
on the trail what are you going to say
you didn't want me why are you he was
pretty much in the basement or in a
truck that is absolutely not true okay
all right jesse wrap it up for us
he made the mistake of trying to
separate the economy from inflation he
kept on saying the economy is great
but i feel your pain with inflation it's
not what you want permission to make an
analogy of course that's like saying to
your buddy your wife's really hot i'm
really sorry that she keeps cheating on
you
you can't separate the two can i take
back the permission yeah the other thing
hold my hand
the other thing he did was now he says
there's nothing i can do you can't tell
the american people there's nothing you
can do if you're the leader of the free
world we gave you the house the senate
we gave you the white house we gave you
air force one we gave you the treasury
department allies
the everything all the normal we give
you a vaccine we give you a recovering
economy and all of a sudden there's
nothing you can do come on and no one
understands that and then he says you
get out there and
i'm going to re-engineer the entire us
economy away from fossil fuels and lower
the world's temperature but i just can't
lower the price of gas a dollar come on
no one believes any of this stuff and
then what he should have done he should
have fired the fed chair when he had the
chance last time his term was up last
month powell's term was up and the guy
choked on inflation remember during the
trump administration he raised rates
and then he froze for the first year of
the biden term and didn't do anything
until it was too late it's like hiring a
drunk pilot i mean he's already lost
control of the plane you think he's
gonna stick the landing at this point
lastly seething about not being able to
get out of the white house more do you
think bush or clinton or obama
would complain that their staff won't
let them do an event they're firing up
the jet and they're going somewhere do a
baby formula factor anywhere just get
out there it reinforces the perception
from the american people that this guy
is powerless and now he's taking a
four-day weekend he was off friday
saturday sunday he's off today no events
and he's not even playing golf like
other presidents that's the question
he wants to and he doesn't even play
golf it's like he's given up and the
american people see it because he's not
playing golf yes and then the complaint
though is that he's
that he wants to go out and do baby
formula events and he's not allowed to
that's not what it is
the president's complaining because they
want to go to delaware for four days
in the middle of all these crises that's
the complaint delaware is not a swing
state and also i just want to last thing
because permission to do this
30 seconds longer um jessica i'm going
to take the opposite view i think the
president could actually
stop doing so many events
stop being out there so much government
should not try to like solve every
single problem take a step back think
about things for a minute have a couple
of days where you're actually thinking
and then go do an event you don't have
to do it doing events is not helping him
at this point all right
well we're gonna have to do an event
it's called a break
that was not what i was thinking
disgusting what was she doing she got
suspended
yeah i thought maybe you would learn a
lesson but apparently not filthy
coming up radical da's facing a
political reckoning after unleashing
anarchy in liberal cities i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now